yeah it's definitely going to be very
exciting I would say that Bragg has a
very technical also quite aggressive
style and Anish has a very theoretical
he style as well he's not afraid of
these Dynamic positions so this means
that we're going to see a big battle
early on in the game and uh there we see
Anish open with the Queen's Pawn it's my
favorite opening with the white pieces
now uh how is Prague going to react to
he develops his night standard stuff and
uh well Anish is always going to play
into the main line so he pushes his uh
Bishop's pawn two squares forward and
there we see Prague approach a very
push open with the e-borne and here we
go very aggressive Choice from Anish
already okay very aggressive uh so it's
the nimso Indian that is characterized
by Black's dark Square Bishop coming out
early and we've just seen that dark
Square Bishop trade itself off for a
night and this is transposing into a
variation we call the samish named after
a very famous player and uh this
position is so imbalanced because look
at white sea pawns they are doubled
right now they're eternally weak but
white has the bishop pair and in the
center of the board white has the
perfect Pawn formation those three pawns
on the fourth rank control a lot of
squares and so there's a lot of
long-term risk here for inish giri
that's why I'm slightly surprised by his
opening Choice he normally doesn't want
to take on these structural defects
these long-term weaknesses uh in terms
of Pawn structure but short term he has
so much potential and Prague actually
with the black king it looks very safe
right now but watch out for it getting
attacked later in the game Anish playing
super fast up to this point just moving
his Knight out the way now the white
Bishops are ready to come out and the
bishop pair also a relevant factor for
later but so what do you think of this
uh opening choice you make a very risky
for both players it is definitely risky
and I have noticed that and when a niche
is successful against Prague it's always
because he chooses very critical
openings you know he puts a pregnant
under on the back foot very early on so
I think this is a perfect choice and I'm
just checking the database and I can see
only three games so I was looking at
where did the players make those unusual
choices
but I have to say within those three
canes it's Even Stevens both players
have one and a half okay so uh Salem
Salah is actually the main practitioner
of this he's played two games first he
beats a roundak sadwani and then he lost
to Daniel ayuffa so two high quality
games yeah so some Grand Masters have
battled it up in this position before
and uh the one thing that's so strange
to me is Anish giri he's playing in this
opening uh choosing this setup this
risky strategy
not this exact position but just until
two moves ago Prague had played this
before himself several times from the
white side so Prague will know all of
the little details all of the nuances
um Anish giri had played this position
from the black side himself and lost
some important games including against
Jordan van forest and by Kansas
including some other big battles so um
yeah it feels as if both players have
adopted the other one's strategy Prague
here playing Black in against an opening
he likes to have with the white pieces
and likewise Gary playing the white side
in a position where he's maybe suffered
with black but has more experience with
the other color and there we go black
did commit his King eventually you
needed to choose which side to put the
King on and uh Gary just continuing with
peace development normally black with
this last move proving this he's going
after the C4 Pawn those two double C
pawns that I mentioned it's the front
Pawn that's the weakest and uh yeah
Craig not hesitating Gary needs to be
aggressive to justify his
yeah his uh wall structure here yeah he
definitely has to be aggressive and I do
remember quite a while ago that this
this kind of Pawn structure was a big
favorite of the U.S champion and not
well previously used women's champion
and Grandmaster Arena crush and she used
to tell me that you know you sometimes
you just forget about that porn that's
under fire at the C4 pawn and you just
focus instead on marching your king side
Pawns in
just forward f for forward and initiate
an attack and that this is very very
dangerous because if you were to look at
Black's King you'll see it's only got
one Defender which is the Knight
yeah and I think we will see those uh
those factors come into play very very
shortly it depends on what Prague does
here and over the next couple of moves
if prank is too slow if he just sits
Waits doesn't really achieve much with
the black pieces then suddenly as you
mentioned Ivanka white is going to start
stepping forward I just really in these
positions as black I always fear this
dark Square Bishop coming out uh White
start Square Bishop is the only
unrivaled piece of its kind and it's
threatening to come out with a really
nasty pin that's going to be hard to
break so we mentioned the weaknesses in
White's position it's this Pawn
the typical move here maybe the most
thematic move would be to go after it
this Pawn is attacked twice it's
actually almost impossible to defend
this Pawn now it's going to drop off the
board and like you said white is just
going to ignore it and she's just going
to for example create that type of pin
or for another idea okay preg has played
this another idea as you mentioned now
Ivanka would be to just continue
marching forward with this pawn and that
is on the board it's the four pawn
attack one of them will drop it is going
to be this C Pawn that's captured I've
guessed now but uh Anish he's going all
out against Black's King we have to say
it mean girls the Mean Girls yes don't
fear them that often we have to mention
it when we do have the Mean Girls on the
board yeah and it's always more
impressive when they're in the center
it's like they control everything pretty
much and that is why I'm expecting
Prague to eliminate one of the gang and
uh for example after a bishop exchange I
think anisha's idea will be to push upon
forward and to just to try and break
lines open towards this black king white
Rook is now about to be on an open Line
white Bishop still has the potential to
come out and create that pin that we
mentioned white white has ideas as well
against a loose Knight on this Square
tickle ideas all over the place and yes
blacks are pulling up but not really
relevant right now and also what's
disconcerting is take a look at anisha's
clock time he's barely paused for
thought this means he's in home
preparation and do you want to be
capturing those pawns when your opponent
has studied everything
these are the thoughts that are running
through pregnant under his mind yeah
it's that psychological warfare that we
always see in the opening between the
top players often both players have
studied similar positions but who knows
more who's gone deeper who's uh kind of
maybe checked his position with an
engine more recently whose coach has
told them all the secrets about these
positions it feels like Anish knows more
than Prague
and uh Prague is on his own he spent
through four minutes now on the clock
since move one
and he has to decide do you capture this
Pawn
the problem is what else uh you're
basically facing an attack no matter
what so you might as well have something
to suffer for so I would expect uh prag
after not too long to pluck up his
courage and grab the white Pawn on C4
yeah we're in for a really really
chaotic game here and uh I just love the
fact that Anish he's starting on the
front foot he's attacking this is what
we've wanted to see from him all season
in each giri and uh he's played it a bit
too safe on occasion not today no not
today it feels like he's a man renewed
actually you know he's you know he
suffered a setback in the global
championships and now he feels like okay
I'm determined I'm gonna change my
Approach and I really love to see this
critical style of Chess being played out
over the board and uh well we do just
while the players are thinking well
there we see porn actually appear on the
board oh we still have the Mean Girls
yeah they're even more perfect right
every single pool and now finally
important drops off the board and uh I
don't think these captures change things
too much I mean the plans are still very
much the same that David mentioned
earlier and uh whilst Anish is pausing
for thoughts oh we have a really cool
question we do have a very cool quiz of
the day we are asking everyone at home
to caption this picture and not this not
this picture no no no no no here we come
here what is David doing and when does
this happen uh we have caption this and
you can answer using the hashtag chess
Champs and we will feature your answers
on the show and remember if you also
want to join in the fun send us
questions send us your selfies you know
so you can do that via the hashtag even
move suggestions or even questions from
Wolves yeah we love all kinds of
interaction questions about life just
anything yeah
we will help you I love them all nice to
see Simon again as well in this picture
so caption this
David sneaking in to Simon's camera oh
sorry Simon I don't even remember when
that was taken to you well because I
could see as he panko in the background
there so it must be from Air things
monsters because that's the only
tournament we had Russian players they
have been not invited on the tour this
season after Russia invaded Ukraine
so sometime during everything's more
services yeah feels like a lifetime ago
yeah but uh back in this game this one
is really dramatic now because uh
something along the lines of what we
explained is happening and ishigiri gave
up that pawn ignoring the whole Queen
side that left side of the board now
he's just saying okay let's swap Bishops
let's do whatever you want there I'm
going for the black king
and he's pushing forward with the F Pawn
it doesn't look too dangerous for the
next couple of moves but if Anish giri
is given the luxury of time then white
start Squad Bishop is coming out lines
will open up even more pawns might step
forward towards that black king prag
needs to find a way to maybe simplify
maybe swap off some pieces
it's still the clock time for me Ivanka
look at Anish giri he's got more time
than he started the game with the
evaluation Bar says it's good for black
but
maybe Anish has looked deeper maybe this
is the type of position that's only fine
for black if he finds a series of really
accurate moves oh that's no guarantee
that Prague will find them I I have to
admit I would be terrified here actually
because you know the ideas that you
mentioned of the dark Square Bishop
jumping out pinning the Knight White's
night on sitting on G3 is also Prime for
Action I I don't know
how to handle this there's no clear-cut
way so it's it's very very scary stuff
for Prague right now yeah and it's I
think it's pretty much
firmed at this point that anishagiri is
still in his home preparation I'm pretty
sure he studied this exact position
before despite the fact nobody in
history has ever reached this position
I'm assuming about her and I mean that's
simply because in this variation in this
position I think pregnant can win a
whole Rook I think he can win material
or at least Anish giri is about to
sacrifice the whole Rook for example as
we jump in
here the most natural move for black
because you're about to get attacked
it's not the one that Craig played this
is very sensible maybe the best move but
I was going to say the most logical move
and is just to automatically capture a
set of Bishops why not trade pieces and
now you can jump in with the Black
Knight you can hit this rook in the
corner hit the bishop hit this Pawn in
the center you can't save all of them
for white and rather than save time
moving The Rook out the way for example
allowing black to come back capture a
pawn black would be two pawns up I think
Anish Gary's preparation will have been
to just let this Rook drop to just give
it away and to go on the attack with
this pin this is what Craig was scared
of hence pushing the H Pawn to stop this
bishop creating the pin and now if the
Rook is captured white leaps forward
with his Knight and due to this uh this
awkward tension suddenly lines will open
up towards the black king it's almost
guaranteed of the Black Knight having
grabbed a rook rushes back for example
suddenly there would be danger Bishop
takes Knight and this is the idea this
is the type of idea at least that
anishikiri is going for he's going for
the black king
so let's go back to the game there have
been developments in this position
rather than capture the Bishops on
anishagiri's terms Prague said okay I'm
going to push forward I'm covering the
dream Square for the white bishop and uh
suddenly after a trade and he just
slides his work across really calm what
is his idea here does he want to bring
it up the board and swing it across
maybe yeah a Rover Rick uh yeah I
definitely think that is the idea again
played almost instantaneously yeah I
mean it has to be the idea you need to
invite all the pieces to the party
you've got to do something now otherwise
you're just a pawn down yeah and it's uh
difficult for Prague actually to break
the tension this tension with the pawns
it looks really nice for white you don't
ever want to get impatient and capture
this Pawn for example as black because
it's only white tonight arrives on the
dream F5 Square this is the perfect
launching pad for any attack it's gonna
sacrifice itself on this square and open
up the black king on one of these two
squares at least so you can't really
touch that pawn if you block it up then
firstly white could ignore this but even
if the position the center gets blocked
white still has this idea of bringing
the Rook up moving the Knight out the
way and then Shifting The Rook across
and due to the pawn structure white has
so much space white has plenty of lines
to attack with
feel so scary for black so yes whites
have fallen down but
I think the pressure is all on Prague
and you can tell this on his camera on
his clock time he's down at seven and a
half minutes it gets 15. that's not
significant wow and it looks like Anish
Guru he's played the perfect opening in
terms of practical chess in terms of
putting the opponent under unbearable
pressure
yeah this one is really heating up let's
go back to the players can Anish turn
this opening preparation into Victory he
needs to strike because he won't catch
Prague unawares like this in the rest of
the games you normally only have one or
two surprises up your sleeve uh in an
opening against a top player and
shot he's trying it now so is it mostly
due to the time that Prague is spending
that you're thinking that he's surprised
he does not know what to do because the
bar is slightly over too bright side
actually
yeah yeah I mean yeah he's spending a
lot of time on the clock but also the
position is so dangerous for black I
mean so many attacking ideas that Prague
has to navigate this very carefully and
there we can see it's like you've become
a fortune teller David by accident you
say it they play it okay they're not
listening to us and now he mobilizes his
work
um
it's a it's just a very very dangerous
position he and when you're surprised
like this you have to react with
cautiously and you have to treat your
opponent's ideas with respect because
everyone is training with computers uh I
say computers is probably super
computers these days yeah so for example
the evaluation bar has gone back to zero
now this is the type of position where
if white gets one strike in one blow
against the black king we'll see the
evaluation by shoot off in White's favor
um it's very unlikely we'll see the
evaluation bar shoot off in Black's
favor unless Anish makes a blunder
somehow or unless he trades pieces and
just ends up in a pawned down end game
but uh due to the fact that there's so
much pressure and it's quite long-term
pressure if you look at the pawn
structure in the middle whites pawns on
the fifth rank black is very cramped
there so white is the one going to
attack and uh yeah I have a feeling
Anish as you mentioned Ivanka he's
looked at this with a super computer
that means he's maybe used stockfish or
Leela zero one of these modern engines
that they will analyze with and he will
have left this type of position on 30
minutes or something for the computer to
break down the numbers this might be the
type of position where we see the bar
which calculates after 30 seconds it
says it's equal but if you leave the
computer running for 30 minutes it might
say that white has a huge initiative and
again black will have to be accurate
remember prag shaking now trying to get
some energy going
and I like what Prague has done just
very calmly brought his Rook to an open
file Black's Knight on that left side of
the board in the white half very active
stopping white from uh especially the
white Bishop from moving but uh yeah
Anish he just needs to find a plan and
then we'll see some big attacking
chances potentially for white and when
you say type of position because
obviously a niche cannot have foreseen
that this exact position after 18 moves
would come on the board so when you say
type of position what similarities will
there be Kings on that side and Pawns in
this kind of exact same structure is
that yeah I mean you yeah you've nailed
it the uh Kaya basically it's this Pawn
structure it's this piece configuration
it will be the plan of attack so I think
we might be in new territory now or move
18 but up until maybe move 15-16 Anisha
played every move instantly he'd uh he'd
at least figured out where he wants to
put the pieces and now probably he knows
where he wants to put the pieces in ish
it's just choosing the order do you to
try that Rook lift that we highlighted a
few moves ago do you want to try that
first do you want to bring the White
Queen out first do you want to tuck
maybe the white king into the corner
first there's lots of ideas that you
want to achieve it's just
maybe figuring out what order to to do
that and then this Pawn structure he
will have studied something along these
lines before
at least that seems to be uh to be the
impression he's giving right now he's
coming down this slightly he's slowing
down so I agree with you I think he's
just simply choosing the move order
because he will have played this
position out he will have looked at ways
for the white pieces to attack the black
king and he will have had experience
here
yep and this is the type of position
where humans will have studied with a
computer maybe a niche he's very
professional you will have played
training games in similar types of
positions but yeah it's always hard to
remember the details
someone like Anish he's probably studied
tens of thousands of opening positions
in his life so sometimes it just takes a
while a couple of minutes to get back in
the zone to get familiar again with the
position
and uh what do you think what will we
see Anish play it feels like he's he's
ready to move almost I think he's going
to lift The Rook two squares forward
yeah
and I think he's just simply working out
what's going to happen if it gets
attacked where it's going to swing to
but to me that's the most natural move I
also quite like you're tucking the king
away into the corner I've been burnt
very recently quite a few number times
but I'm not tucking my king into safety
yeah that feels like a niche Geary type
of move right just Safety First tuck the
white king in the corner and only later
at attack when uh you're fully ready
White's King looks fine right now but it
is on an open diagonal maybe there'll be
some checks later some time gaming
gaining checks so uh yeah it's very
tense and yeah yeah he's played a great
opening he just needs to back it up now
Prague probably happy to see Anish
finally thinking he makes uh a night
jump instead something wow not what you
expected I can see no yeah not yet at
least I thought he would prepare this
maybe with the Rook swinging up first
but okay he's setting some traps for
Prague Prague can get greedy and grab
another Pawn in the center but I think
that would backfire basically Anish is
trying to remove Black's only Defender
that black knight is about to get traded
off for white tonight and wow
interesting move by Prague retreating
blacks Knight that is purely designed
Against The Rook lift remember White's
Rook on the B5 wanted to lift up two
squares and swing across that's no
longer possible black tonight on the
other edge of the board
covering that definitely they're
breaking the rules now they're playing
with us nice on the rumor dim guys what
are you doing yeah they are finding some
very creative news cool game first one
today on day two in the Champions chess
tour finals and uh Prague he uh comes
inspired to the board today because it
was announced earlier today that he is
the recipient of a big sports award in
India and Tanya of course International
master from India yourself what is this
big award that Prague has received
it is the second highest sporting honor
of the country that's given by the
government of India and it's truly the
dream of every athlete to win the Arjuna
award it just means so much it's a big
recognition for all the efforts and the
success
wow uh and Prague actually tweeted about
receiving this award so and you say it's
a dream for any uh Sports person in
India here we see the Tweet as well
truly blessed and honored to have
received this award how big is it for an
athlete and a sports person in India to
receive this
it's huge like I was saying and since
2013 there hasn't been a single chess
player who's won the Arjuna award every
year around 15 to 25 athletes from
different categories are announced they
win this award and it's been a long time
since the chess player did so for Prague
means a lot uh I actually won it in 2009
so I know exactly what this feels like
and it's a huge deal in India it's the
president of India who gives this award
so a big moment for the family for the
friends uh and means so much for the
athlete wow fantastic Tonya and there
are so many young Indian chess players
nowadays why do you think it was exactly
Prague who received it
there were a lot of applications that
were sent and received but then they
it's it's such a process and there's so
much due diligence performance is
measured uh the the kind of success the
athlete has achieved how many medals
they want for the country and products
just done so much of that over the last
and it's not just over a period of 12
months over a period of a year but they
take into account a couple of years see
your performance see your growth in the
sport and I have to say it was that
moment when Prague beat Magnus for the
first time first time back in February
uh the Athens tournament which really
exploded in India and everyone took
notice of it including some of the
biggest names in the Indian government
as well and I think probably just it's
just such a well-deserved award after
his performance at the Olympiad
throughout the Champions chest
fantastic thank you for that inside
Tanya how cool that right now we have
two recipients of the Arjuna Awards in
uh this picture thank you Tanya
how cool
receiving a huge Indian sports award
entering this game and the bar is now
more over to his side is this going in
his favor do you think potentially and
that's because of a bit of a strange
move by Anish giri on the previous turn
we mentioned that White's Rook wanted to
lift up the board it did lift up the
board but it's not swinging anywhere
White's Rook on the B4 Square maybe a
bit misplaced and uh now I mean she's
sacrificing a second Pawn
um let's go back a couple of moves this
is the current position white has just
put his Bishop to attack the black Rook
but here I think White had several
tempting opportunities uh for example
the queen could just develop but White's
Rook lifted and the reason it's not a
good move the reason the computer
dislikes it is because it's blocked by
its own pawn it wants to jump over its
own pawn and swing towards the black
king but that's not possible Black's
Rook activated and here
several opportunities for products
several attempting moves maybe he could
have just been greedy maybe he could
have grabbed a second Pawn but now the
evaluation bar reacts the other way
because Prague has tried to pin the
white Bishop but
the black Rook is on a loose Square what
could be the downside to this move
I don't see why immediately the computer
favors white suddenly The Rook looks
like it's very active maybe it's just
because it can be hit in a few different
ways the White Queen can attack this
Rook from this side the White Queen can
attack The Rook from this side
very strange very hard to evaluate
position to me at least it's very
difficult I mean and it's not obvious to
human eye because I was also confused so
the computer analysis is simply as you
say The Rook can be attacked and uh I
mean it's just unbelievable actually
that you think that White's attack is
going to be worth two pawns because
after black captures the second Pawn
it's saying after the Knight takes night
now Queen takes note the bishop can come
back to see one to starting Square
attack the rook and The Rook is the
forced to go to the A1 square and it's
trapped it's got no squares yeah it's
trapped wow so Anish Guri could maybe
trap the black Rook it's not the end of
the world for Prague here he can give
his Rook up for a bishop and here we
would see a material balance of Knight
and two pawns for one of White's Rooks
so it's actually level material but the
reason the computer probably favors
white in this type of position is
because it's the Rooks that are superior
to the Black Knight White's Rook is
ready to infiltrate it's on an open file
Black's Knight is sidelined so maybe
that old adage that Knights on the river
didn't maybe that will become very
relevant but it's not easy to see in
this type of position uh in the game
position that we have right now on the
board that this Rook is about to get
trapped it's centralized centralized
pieces are the hardest ones uh to cage
and uh Anish he finds it of course he
finds it great maneuver here and it's a
key detail that after Rook takes Bishop
if the Rook Trust give itself up you
don't capture The Rook automatically you
play as Vision as Vision Chuck here in
between check
and uh first you play Knight takes
Knight check otherwise black would have
captured your night next move and only
after black takes you back then you win
the black Rook so wow this is really
clever geometry from anishagiri and uh
here Ivanka maybe since this Rook is
about to get trapped maybe it has to
step back and offer a trade for white
Rook otherwise you just have to give it
up for a white Bishop right this is uh
really difficult to evaluate it is
really difficult but the problem is that
black has there are lots of bad pieces
and so you're stepping back with a rook
actually would be a worse solution wow I
mean this is really difficult to see
again and anticipate because after
Knight takes a knight again the queen
will capture and then you ask the
question once more to The Rook
Bishop attacks the rook and then after
Rook takes Rook this is so long and so
difficult and diff and uh the question
is to the night yeah where are you gonna
go you don't have any safer squares you
get a call it's Ghostbusters um this
night is just a terrible piece right now
I mean the White Queen is going to start
in entering the black Camp winning some
pawns and this would have been terminal
for Prague so he did indeed get greedy
here and uh he didn't go back with his
rookie instead he grabbed a pawn but
sorry with this Square uh taking a Pawn
on E3 and now we are expecting Anish
giri to swap off the knights keep things
simple and just go back to trap this
black Rook anishikiri has the advantage
I think Prague with that misstep putting
his Rook on the wrong square has passed
the advantage over to Gary and suddenly
everything to play for Prague is gonna
have to be very creative he's going to
show have to show all of the
resourcefulness he's he's proved
throughout the season just to save this
game
and uh I think any Shigeru he will after
a bit of a think find this maneuver
Bishop Retreats are quite hard to see
sometimes but there's nothing else you
have to try and trap that black Rook
yeah and uh Anisha is very good at
spotting those targets so I think you'll
see it and as I've learned this weekend
Brooks are better than knights
in all three games I played three games
last weekend and in every single game I
was The Rook for a night down and I was
like when it happened the third time I
was just like looking at I was just like
don't ask
I don't know how this happened like fate
is laughing at me and now it's showing
me again that I need to brush up on
defensive skills yeah so maybe Prague
will I mean he's basically in the shoes
that you were in in your three games
yeah
and if this is not the Universe telling
me something it happened yesterday in a
couple of games I know that we commented
on
Goodness Me
and uh
what's the Anish is considering his move
you know will he spot that backward
bishop move well we have a captioned
this competition and Richard Harding
captions the picture saying did I just
see the scroll opening
and dark fur says we all have that one
friend
yes David David is actually really good
at photo bombing pictures like this
I have one where he managed to get in
between actually Anna kramlin and Pierre
cramlin he can manage to get in between
their faces yeah I felt really guilty
because it was a really nice mother
daughter photo and they just had their
arms around each other but I was
standing behind and I managed I appeared
in the little bit between them
my favorite thing is photo bombing sorry
Simon some great captions keep it up and
what is Gary doing here because
we thought he would trade off for
Black's night oh he's just given up his
night for a pawn is this I mean either
this is genius or as a mouse slip he's
given up why it's night and also White's
Knight is trapped on this Square so the
question is does Prague even take this
Knight now or does he have something
better
think and issues idea here is to just go
purely on the attack and go all out for
the black king he's hoping that he's
luring the black king out into the open
onto a vulnerable dark square but
computer says it doesn't work
Prague he's got four and a half minutes
can he find the solution can he find the
refutation of White's move and we have
to jump in uh because yeah I was gonna
say it looked like Anish was super calm
in the beginning after making that move
but then he started shaking started
shaking and here anisha's idea he's
given up his Knight if the Knight is
captured then the White Queen steps back
hitting the black Rook but also lining
up with her Bishop against this weak
Pawn if the black Rook saves itself now
I'm not sure where it goes then Bishop
takes Pawn this does look very scary the
black king doesn't have many protectors
around the White Queen is swooping in
it's still very complicated maybe Anish
uh he has some attack here at least
maybe he can try and deliver Checkmate
but
Ivanka I must admit I took a peek here
because it's so hard to spot this move
the winning move for black the winning
move is not to get greedy and take this
Knight yeah yeah I also took a peek as
well but it makes sense I mean the whole
thing is that winning your king is in
danger you should trade of queens and so
you just simply offer a trade of Queens
yeah the best move is just a simple side
step with the black queen not only do
you offer the trade of Queens but you
take away the route towards Plex King
from the White Queen White Queen wanted
to step back remember utilizing this
diagonal but also this diagonal but now
due to the tension on the c-file White
Queen has no way forward if you don't
trade Queens the only way is to step
back and now Black's King will take the
Knight okay he didn't find this
pregnantanda so now we're gonna see fire
on the board but here white would just
be a piece down Prague could have been a
piece up for nothing
um the queen trade remember here would
favor uh black because white tonight is
trapped this Knight has no way back it's
going to be taken going to be captured
and uh okay he didn't find this he had a
lot of time Prague I'm slightly
surprised he was looking for options but
he took the Knight and now he is gonna
face a double threat the queen is
attacking the rook and the bishop is
attacking this Pawn
the computer still prefers black
slightly but with such a weak King
there's no guarantees anymore
one moment of drama we didn't expect
that we thought Anisha was going to go
and show us the calm the simple way of
uh playing he could have just trapped
The Rook for free he's given up his
night in the process
well that's the thing though you know
when you're kind of primed for attacking
the king I guess his attention was
focused in that direction I also didn't
even dream about this uh sacrificial
idea I mean we could it could be an
inspired moment of Genius it could work
out I mean and everything to play for
and the players now locked in thought
and just looking at the time situation
is he pregnant doesn't have so much time
just over two minutes
just over two minutes and especially
when you're the one who's been surprised
that definitely would have come as a
surprise to Prague shocked us here in
the studio
um yeah two minutes is not really enough
so okay the Black Brook did save itself
and uh now takes a pawn and then the
king sidesteps but now it's going to be
all about the White Queen mobilizing
yeah the one issue for anishia the one
issue for white is that the Rooks can't
join the attack there's no way for that
white Rook on the left side of the board
to ever re-route itself towards the
black king the other white Rook wants to
step up the board but it would only get
traded off by Black's Rook blacks Rook
on the third rank does a great job
actually of controlling some key squares
so what do we do here I mean if we're
materialistic we're a piece down we
could regain some of the material
White's Bishop could go and take Black's
Rook but after the bishop is recaptured
suddenly we have two knights against a
rook that still does favor the two
knights
and the white Rex just not able to
mobilize themselves as you say not able
to join in the attack I mean somehow if
we could transplant that Rook sitting on
D3 just kind of flick it away move it
away then white is going to be winning
but um it's not easy to do actually you
cannot chase that Rook
Rook away or maybe you can yeah maybe
you can but uh the problem is how do we
kick this Rook away we need the White
Queen to attack this black rook in the
middle of the board but the queen is
teamed up with this bishop you can't
lose protection of that piece
you can threaten Checkmate in one move
here for example let's jump back into
the game it's so critical right now
um the game will be decided over the
next few moves so at least the momentum
will be uh you could threaten Checkmate
White Queen could jump in trying to
slide up next to the king and trap it
but maybe this is what a niche missed
that after The Rook slides across
defending there's no more entry squares
for the White Queen if you slide back
this looks scary again threatening a
discovered check against the black king
but blacks Rooks now they just kick the
White Queen away there's no more
attacking squares for the White Queen
she has to retreat and she will lose her
Bishop so in the current position
um you mentioned at Ivanka maybe you
need to just get rid of this Rook but
first
yeah you need to just take this piece
the reason I'm reluctant is because now
you're only attacking with a white Queen
you can jump back in again but Black's
Queen will offer up an exchange
exchanges will help black two nights
long term will beat a white rook and uh
yeah it's it feels like the attack is
fizzling out finish giri he needs some
magic dust uh he needs to sprinkle
something on this position and he tries
not by being materialistic but by going
for a pin
is this going to work Prague says okay
I'm just going to bring another piece to
the defense and still the idea is there
of just simplifying perhaps trading off
The Rook for the bishop yeah and uh
trading into an end game
exactly what is attacking just with the
bishop now so why not get rid of it next
move Prague is a whole night ahead so he
has the opportunity that's often the
best way to kill an opponent's attack
give back some of the material they
sacrificed just to get pieces off the
board just to water the position down
into an end game and it's also such a
great move from from Prague because it
also ties down the queen so I really
like anisha's last move so this means
the queen can now move from this dark uh
long this dark diagonal and perhaps a
step up one square attack the rook and
get ready to move over to the E2 Square
oh wow okay very calm brings his Knight
in this looks like a blunder at first
because it looks like two pieces will be
attacked the night now and The Rook but
Black's Knight can just Retreat uh to a
protected square and save its Rook
evaluation bar loving what Prague is
doing right now and rightly so he's
recentralized his Knight assuming that
this happens he's recentralized his
Knight and everything's protected the
Knight protects the Rook the Knight
itself is defended white Central Pawn is
under Fire feels like a niche he got a
bit overexcited went for the attack when
it wasn't really there he could have
played it calmly
Prague yeah so calm he's a great
defender that's one thing we haven't
given credit for this season uh so much
because we're so impressed by his
counter-attacks his his kind of play on
the front foot but when players go for
his throat he's happily uh he's very
calm uh he's just yeah he always seems
to find a way to re-coordinate his
pieces
yeah I remember him doing it against
Jordan van Forrest
exactly the same scenario sharp position
and he just handled the complications
beautifully and uh one on the counter
attack and talking about counter-attack
prag is completely winning here look how
he's maneuvering his pieces so they can
protect each other and the queen moves
two squares to the right
yeah that
that decisive I mean not only is it
critical now on the board but the clock
you need to create something here for
white you need some trap for black to
fall into but how do you get those
creative juices flowing when you've got
less than a minute on the clock when
you're a whole piece down running out of
material White Queen can't deliver a
single check that's the key Black's Rook
is no longer trapped like it was in the
previous variations that you showed you
Ivanka yeah and why it's Works still no
good
they just don't have an open line to
fire down you kind of want to pick up
all of White's pawns and throw them off
the board and say okay at least now I
have some open lines for my Rooks
exactly uh no anisha's pawns block his
own pieces
and under 15 seconds for Anish giri his
body language does not look positive he
almost looks as if he's kind of uh
resigning himself to the fact he is lost
okay it's desperate times when you're a
whole piece down and you have nothing
better than shuffling your king into the
corner this would have been a good move
10 15 moves ago but
it's too late for that and uh Prague
clinical clinically pushing the a pawn
forward
is very difficult to recommend a plan
for a niche
I mean
keep rolling exactly yeah
there's no threat whatsoever on the
board
and there you go attacking The Rook one
more time Rook is forced to step back
and he's offering a trade I think this
is a good idea because Black's work it
was so aggressive it was such a nuisance
yeah
particularly does this work black can
swap a pair of Rooks and whites Pawn in
the center look at White's E4 Pawn both
the Black Knights are staring down at it
it's gonna fall and with it that should
be the end of any curious chances he's
looking away drinking some water 30
seconds on the clock
it's beyond saving now this position
it's a big missed opportunity for an
Asia and I agree his position is just
collapsing yeah it's it's so strange
what he did in a way is just that Knight
takes porn move
it was a blunder for several different
reasons actually and it feels like Anish
played that earlier blunder by Instinct
without backing it up with calculation
and unfortunately at the top level
especially against players like Prague
who are so accurate with their
calculation
can't get away with that and uh yeah
after a trade of Rooks blacks Knight did
snack on a pawn right now black is a
knight and a pawn ahead
and minimal threats the Black Knights
defend each other perfectly
still no tracks against the black king
yeah it's just all about uh pushing the
pawns actually on the left side of the
board I mean no threat as you say and he
just moves with his Queen this is also
great technique Queen is threatening to
come in or to the fourth row
balls are going to get pushed nothing
for Anish to do now yeah he's run out of
pieces
and uh I was praising his opening I
still think it was a great choice he got
a fantastic position out the opening
great chances but
yeah if you don't back up an opening
with really consistent play really
accurate energetic play
and of course for a calculation then
things might fall apart and it's always
risky against someone like Prague
15 seconds I think we'll see Anish
resign how about you Banker yeah no
chance left just resign now yeah
someone has to uh yeah you went down to
six seconds on the clock there and Anish
and he lifts his Rook but we wanted to
lift The Rook up the board ages ago now
any Rook swings are blocked by white
zone pieces the White H Pawn is in the
way of any checks Black's King safe as
houses as they say
no chance and yeah he's just going
through the motions
Prague is going to wrap up this win in
short measure activating the black queen
and nothing else to do yeah I just like
the way that Prague is playing you know
he's taken full control here
and we have a result Craig takes the
first game of the match wow look at that
Anna nishkiri he just rushes off it's uh
Prague who takes